the government my name
welcome back to another I am I looking
at myself alright welcome back is more
heavily abreast
Tobuscus quick son of a [ __ ] alright
welcome to Tobuscus quiz party
hi Shelly and really question son of a
[ __ ] bye ah [ __ ] alright how many
literal tree how does [ __ ] knows that
I'm sorry
alright I'm gonna guess at 27
ah alright can I buy you like my ass boy
got that all on the floor are the Holly
to Dubai
shut up it's Ted Africa alright just the
fun don't move alright it's so much fun
whoa
that's I read your foot man
whoa why are you get out why'd I add
there's the foot oh no we're gonna get
shot
we're gonna get shot made it Oh waiter
he lives
it's a merit what ah that's a shame
let's see if we can get loose come on
nobody can do it there you go
oh never mind but another [ __ ] ball
around these are still so popular all
right turn that down what I need you get
up
all right let's go shut up buy it
we're fine all right get a kick start on
this [ __ ]
so let's say something oh you made it
son stupid games son of a-- nice
backflip that's how I roll uh shut that
ah my leg my neck everything front left
Bastian ah [ __ ] ah but my legs dicks
exploded ah
what am i doing I'm eating my own deck
[ __ ] okay let's try it yeah stop sucking
your penis boy that's what you get you
little [ __ ] I'm gonna finish this soda
start
elevator huh reattach reattach ah shucks
dad what what what am i doing so I die
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] dami guy son what it go
all right [ __ ] yeah here we go
yeah we go [ __ ] yeah ah I'm so sad what
did that thing Dingling it's my panic
shot
disgusting that's character uh uh epic
t1 this is do it
wait are we gonna write on TV to the
side
let's go sad [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that in
workout workout when I walk industry
dancing dancing dancing I'm a dolphin
dolphin dolphin dancing dolphin
PewDiePie part I mean no sense I'm sorry
hi here we go [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
alright here we go again
wow what am i doing let go mate piece of
[ __ ] nice Oh delicious
oh I'm adding calories son of a dear hey
hey hey hey man hide it alright [ __ ]
shrine hugger
Norman shut up all right ahead Joe it's
too good at these swords though okay I'm
not really that good I'm just kidding
I don't know jade is that real JB this
is what you I share I miss Barry Dalits
are power anyone wants it
oh I catch it and I eat it and then I
scratch my back with it and then I die
you see this [ __ ]
what I do my [ __ ] arm des are you're
not the caller arm there we go
all right arm sword that's how I roll
that's how I get to the ladies now get
the girl that's right why did I tell you
what about our oh yes if I get to the
ladies sorry about that
I don't know whatever done Jay made this
one is for your penis that's a [ __ ]
the best thing ever said let's get the
jet packs
go jet Oh what the [ __ ] come on double-o
and I caught it with my face
that's how I roll [ __ ] you JB [ __ ] yeah
that's right get the old man with you
all right come on
Santa I didn't mean to kiss them sorry
about that sandy sandy you the man there
we go yeah hi to Nadia I mean to the
football Emma but [ __ ] you thought I was
JB [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm okay I'm
actually God ah no no no no no we're not
Jamie oh no shut up back there
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you ball stop
bang yes I'm gay anyways watch with the
[ __ ] expert yes ja what am I doing with
my life
it's buzz don't I'm gay and I just will
admit it I am Justin Bieber and I'm gay
god dammit god dammit I'm also Hitler
see no I'm not gonna say it people will
think it's offensive
all right there we go there we go oh
[ __ ] yeah no thank you [ __ ] piece of
ball you better be jet pack it nah [ __ ]
it on my next bike Oh tour for fatality
I just know there's gonna be a big you
have an egg give me that [ __ ] front flap
I said it's stuck it's stuck
hey what you doing what am i doing
humping the hammer oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah we're going hammer
oh no hammer why did you do it I'm keep
doing it anyway
why not I'm a giraffe humping a hammer
it's just how it is in life you know
people told me in school Oh what am I
going to new adventures I don't know
where I'm going but all that matters is
I have a hammer shut up
sons of [ __ ]
double backflip on you stop but what am
i doing
dr. Helen that my penis fellas oh here
we go
ed got I want to do it properly
grab it leg you're not supposed to catch
it mm no Santa's gonna [ __ ] well God
okay
my life is no I'd better right now ooh
it's a hard quiz if it's gonna be
questions like the Tobuscus one like you
I I didn't know which date I started my
channel I don't even know how many
videos I come on
sometimes you gotta flirt with him maybe
say this is a very difficult quest
all right what is my first and last name
Civ and Gustav something my name is
Felix Kjellberg [ __ ] now everyone's
gonna stalk my dad it's actually neither
of these it's razor Karachi
but Megalodon looks pretty [ __ ]
similar so whatever where is she's
remain today [ __ ] yeah I'm too good a
dead shut up all right
it's shut up what breathe dogs I have
that's that fine
son of [ __ ] I knew that fantastic get
your ass up shut up like that all right
what is this it's purely off come in
here I tell you
[ __ ] yeah it feels really stupid putting
myself is awesome but
I guess I gotta do it throw the kids
let's do it for the kids let's do it for
the kids all right [ __ ] hey no prob
much shut up you're not allowed to sing
that [ __ ] what are you doing what the
hell man oh wow
I got your legs [ __ ] off shut up shut
your mouth shut your mouth go back in
Bennett in it kiss each other kill him
do something weird I don't [ __ ] know
I got y'all peanuts wait I didn't wait I
got it
that is eat it and [ __ ] off that's how I
roll oh let me catch the penis let me
catch the penis what are you doing
you're not a penis [ __ ] off
very nice but sorry I don't know what
the [ __ ] that was Peter PI's chair run
sounds pretty decent sounds pretty
amazing dad remote activate I okay back
there
[ __ ] yeah first try [ __ ] ass that's how
I roll yes I like it
I let's let's finish it off for the
lesson space does it's gotta be good I'm
really I don't know if you can tell
really [ __ ] tired today
I didn't sleep at all ah shut up it's
scary
are you okay that man he died recently
who did all of it it was me shut up back
there
son of [ __ ] you could never do with
Dutton whoa what is this contamination
please wait while the machine transfer
whoa enter generator ah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
all right what is this get out out [ __ ]
what all right I know we broke your bike
you would pay for this son shut up what
do you know about [ __ ] huh what
it's so [ __ ] loud all right here we
go what oh no I don't like this shut up
shut up so much I say I don't here we go
eat it whoa you come back here you
little [ __ ]
give me back my head
come on what the hell how did that all
right
fat lady I like your budget
all right here we go good don't die
don't die fat sack ba ba
yeah then ro that's how you get an itch
shut up you don't know what I'm gonna
say hey no chops
Chablis Shh all right you don't need to
know details all right here we go
oops webs all right what is it what so
many noise where the hell is going on
right now is that green thing we go down
to [ __ ] it down front flip Oh what no we
nearly died again
whoops sorry bye dad whoops
this is excited about nah no no no so I
know hey what is this oh not another one
Ron Bharat what the [ __ ] did he just say
Adam [ __ ] forget Matt I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was saying doing it
though
but anyway like vidvision you I'd this
guy converse today and I'll see you next
episode
Oh forever iMac stay awesome bros I know
you will
[Music]
fayla we're doing hi hi hi hi hi hi